so I want to talk about attack on Titan
and lost really I'm going to be talking
about attack on Titan even though
largely I'm going to be talking about
lost well let's let's now let's just
roll back to the beating okay so I
started watching attack on Titan and I
made it about half way through the first
season when my like BS meter started
like going off like a klaxon something
something was wrong something was off so
I decided that it was time and I just i
Doan - all the spoilers
I read you know I started pulling up
summaries all the way through - like
everything that's being published now in
the manga and you know it's like okay
what's going on what's the meta plot
what do we know what do we not know and
I noticed a pattern and now we're going
to talk about lost so lost fell victim
to a common problem with broadcast
television which is that the serial
content for broadcast television is
generally intended to go on for as long
as humanly possible
you make a series and the goal at
minimum is well six seasons in a movie
but realistically like everyone is kind
of hoping to be the next law in order or
the next simpsons with 20-plus seasons
or something like mash with decades of
syndication but that's just not feasible
and it's not really sustainable because
the narrative economy is largely based
on novelty being able to generate new
episodes being able to generate new
ideas being able to consistently engage
the audience in a way that is both
familiar and surprising that need
essentially in this economic metaphor
can lead to unsustainable inflation and
of course the tipping moment is usually
referred to as jumping the shark loss
suffered dramatically as a result of
this need to keep things going the show
was initially pitched to the audience as
a mystery and the need for mysteries the
constantly inflating need for new
mysteries bloated the series in a
completely unsustainable way to the
point that by the time we were in like
the fifth and sixth season they were
trying to wrap stuff up and but there
was it was impossible at that point
there was no way that they were going to
be able to wrap stuff up because there
was too many hanging threads
there were there were mysteries that
they had cooked up in season one with no
clue how they were ever going to resolve
them and they just never came back to
them ever ever and they were just they
were left completely unresolved and a
lot of fans did not react positively to
that everything I'm saying here I'm
saying about lost but I'm actually
saying it about attack on Titan these
problems are not just a problem with the
show needing to Pat itself out in order
to avoid catching up with the manga
these are actually problems that are
core to the manga itself because the
manga is also a serial production now
this is not a condemnation inventing
things by the seat of your pants is not
a bad way of doing things it's just a
chaotic and unorganized way of doing
things for example the Mongoose a Maki
was also being developed by the
seat-of-the-pants in a largely
serialized self-perpetuating way however
as it neared the end of its run Ito is
able to pull all of those together into
a very tight very cohesive ending that
really really resonates it's a great
ending fantastic ending and fantastic
resolution to the series so just because
you're kind of just making stuff up as
you go that doesn't mean you're doomed
it does however mean that you're
potentially at risk of falling victim to
the same kind of ending as lost where
you have created so many twists and so
many mysteries that your entire world is
now just one giant pile of self
contradictory information and there is
no way to resolve it in any satisfactory
way